There are no wizards doctor strange is a sorcerer
a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat every time
we fight we fight one of the three so who are you
fighting now gandalf how do you know about gandalf
i read the hobbit in 1937 when it first came out
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
falcon and winter soldier episode 2 video there
were a whole bunch of marvel easter eggs for the
movies from the comics so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel i'm doing
videos for all the episodes so be sure to
subscribe to get everything we're also doing
a giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter just be a subscriber and
leave your favorite moment from the episode
on the video careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the episode yet obviously it will just
go through the episode shop by shot and talk about
easter eggs as we go along starting with the title
of the episode the star-spangled man that's a
direct reference to us agent captain america they
even call him the star-spangled man during the
actual episode he is john walker from the comics
even if you're not a huge comic book reader you've
probably at least heard of us agent or john walker
at some point he's been a version of captain
america in the comics before so this is them just
doing the comic book plot he was actually kind
of a captain america villain for a little while
but the way they play him in the episode is
trying to be a little bit more complex about it
like they try to bill him as the perfect candidate
for the next captain america at least on paper
you can kind of see where things slowly start to
go off the rails a little bit they're trying to
lay the seeds for that like they just introduced
this character so it's going to be an episode or
two before he really starts to go off the rails
so you kind of see how they're laying the seeds
for the idea that maybe falcon is potentially
the better candidate for captain america like
that's the whole idea of the series that he was
supposed to become the next captain america but
he chose not to when he gave the shield back but
the whole idea with the star-spangled name is that
it also reminds you of star spangled banner is in
a reference to the flag and that's juxtaposed with
the villain group the flag smashers as in the us
agent smashers which she does later in the episode
really easy way to find out that he has not been
enhanced quote-unquote in any way at least yet
so we'll get to that because there's all the super
soldier serum stuff flying around on the show now
the actual episode begins though with him
unzipping his jacket to you know basically
unveil himself in his new captain america costume
which is based on his comic book costume except
it's more blue than it is black like he had
a couple different variations of the costume
when he was captain america you find out that
they've gone back to his hometown high school
to unveil him to the world as new captain america
but he's sort of in the middle of this pr tour so
they've been doing this all over the place the
opening theme song is different they're kind of
doing the Wandavision thing where the opening
theme songs are just a little bit different in
each of the episodes but this time it's the band
later that's actually playing him onto the field
in that whole opening speech of his where he's
trying to wrap his mind around the expectations
that the world has for him and not wanting to let
them down in becoming the new captain america is
just to let you know that he's at least trying to
be a good captain america the way the producers
and the writers talk about his character and the
way they're using him on the series is that you
could be doing everything right but still not be
the right person for the job so that's the whole
idea is that he's perfect on paper but he still
won't be the right person to be the next captain
america that's supposed to be falcon you meet his
friend lamar hoskins who is based on a comic book
character battle star he even says later in the
episode oh my name's battlestar and bucky's like
what at least in the comics battle star did get a
version of super strength and abilities from the
power broker who is a character that it seems like
they're doing on the tv series they referenced his
name during the episode but it's still a bit
of a mystery as to who he actually is most of
battlestar's abilities were like lesser versions
of what happened to captain america the whole idea
with a power broker character there was an easter
egg for him during the credits last week so just
confirming that he is going to be a big character
on the show he was the head of a criminal
organization that later tried to replicate the
super soldier serum and it's kind of what's
happening on the show right now in falcon and
winter soldier like the flag smashers bucky says
there are eight new super soldiers running around
where did they get their super soldier serum from
because they all sound like they're british they
do this big highlight reel for us agent showing
you all of his accomplishments his awards all of
his stats off like he was always top of his class
and everything top performance in the military
he has all these awards for heroism he's like the
model soldier that everyone would normally look
up to like i said the whole idea is that he's
meant to be perfect on paper in terms of possibly
becoming the next captain america he references
iron man and the hulk even though he calls him dr
banner remember the world knows about the avengers
they're all celebrities in a certain sense and
they even reference that later in the episode
when falcon almost gets arrested by those regular
uniform cops like oh crap you're the avengers
sorry he compares himself to steve rogers captain
america a little he explains his timeline in the
mcu as well he says he was just at a west point
when cap came out of the ice in the first avengers
movie which is like college for military officers
so all through the timeline of the avengers movies
he was following and watching captain america just
trying to copy all of his moves sort of like a
captain america fanboy like i'm sure all military
officers were captain america fanboys but then you
cut to bucky's reaction as he's watching this all
unfold like he just can't believe this and i love
that he's still sitting on the floor like he still
hasn't gotten himself any furniture which i think
is just a function of his ptsd his reaction is
pretty much the exact same reaction that roadie
war machine had in episode one like dude what are
you doing why are you giving the shield back this
is the worst thing that you could possibly be
doing right now then you get falcon's reaction
staring at the new captain america poster at the
air force base where he runs all of his missions
out of bucky takes him to task telling him captain
america would not want this steve gave you the
shield for a reason this is sort of an ongoing
argument that they have throughout the entire
episode and obviously it's going to continue in
future episodes because bucky's just going to be
on him until finally he comes around and says okay
fine i'll take the shield back i will be the new
captain america they try to cut the tension by
transitioning to that funny doctor strange scene
that we all saw in the trailers falcon explains
the flag smashers group the mission he's going on
but he name drops the big three and i also love
that they reference this later with u.s agents
character like oh you're talking about the big
three like the big three is meant to be this
common term that all military officers supposedly
use androids aliens and wizards which obviously is
a reference to thanos also the events of the first
avengers movie with the shit-towering invasion
androids as a reference to ultron and wizards i
guess you could say as a reference to kaiselius
in the doctor strange movie maybe they think
of loki as a wizard technically loki isn't a
sorcerer either then bucky surprises everyone
by showing you he's a bigger nerd than you ever
thought that he was he totally understands magic
classes he's right doctor strange is not a wizard
falcon also technically correct in that sorcerers
are like wizards without hats they got into
different magic classes a little bit during
Wandavision like the whole idea that scarlet
witch draws her power from a different source than
doctor strange draws his power from and agatha
harkness draws her power from a different source
than both of them bucky makes his big gandalf
hobbit reference and the whole idea what he knows
about gandalf is because he read the hobbit when
it was originally published back in 1937. just
for reference he would have been in his early
20s when that happened i'm assuming he and steve
rogers because they grew up together as friends he
would have also probably read the hobbit as well
but the reason why he's referencing the hobbit
instead of connecting gandalf to the lord of the
rings which are technically a more famous story
is because the hobbit was published first the lord
of the rings books like fellowship of the rings
wasn't published until the 1950s and by that time
bucky would have fully become the winter soldier
for hydra and been in cryostasis between missions
in that siberia base also in the 1950s they would
have been the korean war so that's also just after
he would have run into isaiah bradley and had his
big fight with him don't worry we'll talk all
about isaiah bradley in a second i was so happy
that they included him in this episode it was one
of the coolest easter eggs they've done so far
they go on the mission to germany and they
know a little bit about the flag smashers
but it takes them the rest of the episode before
they learn that carly morgenthau is their leader
erin kellyman's character so she's based on the
comic book version of flagsmasher even though
they're using the flag smasher name for their
entire group but if it wasn't clear she's meant
to be the leader of their group they have their
funny bro off moment just their staring contest
foreshadowing the later staring contest that
they have when they're in that therapy session
when they have that conversation about him not
having a plan like oh great that's actually a
callback to the first avengers movie and the
winter soldier movie iron man had pretty much
the exact same scene i do have a plan attack as he
jumps out the back of the quinjet captain america
had a similar moment at the beginning of the
winter soldier movie when he just casually talks
about his plan with black widow then jumps out the
back without a parachute also bucky hilariously
having to jump out of the back of the plane
without a parachute like i'll probably be okay
it's only about 200 feet they investigate the flag
smashers moving those shipments of vaccine they're
pulling their whole robin hood operation later in
the episode they clarify that they're basically
stealing supplies like medicine and taking it
to displaced communities all over europe because
since the blip governments of the world are trying
to work together to get everybody back to where
they originally came from you have to imagine
after the snap the world kind of shifted around
looking for more resources so everybody wound up
living in very different places from where they
originally came from but then they have the funny
moment with winter soldier thinking that she's
this lost little girl and she just kicks him right
out the back and he discovers that they're all
super soldiers we have eight new super soldiers
it's really cool action scene that totally feels
in the tone of a buddy cop movie there's a bit of
a funny moment where she totally destroys red wing
on the spot everybody pressed f in the chat to pay
respects red wing did nothing wrong then an even
funnier moment when us agent captain america flies
in with battle star and they're playing it as if
they're meant to be the better version of falcon
and winter soldier but they both too get their
asses handed to them mostly because u.s agent
does not have any enhancements or super soldier
serum yet there were a couple moments where they
showed you some of bucky's abilities too because
he has the super soldier serum so he can run super
fast just like captain america but the reason why
they are able to pin him down is because they all
have the super soldier serum or a version of it
they follow it up with another funny wtf awkward
moment when u.s agent and his buddy battlestar
roll up and try to get them into the car like
he's trying to be a nice guy like hey why don't
we work together but kind of casually reveals
that the government has been spying on falcon
this whole time well you know technically red
wing was government property so is it really
bad for us to be spying on you if it's our
property the answer is yes yes it's still bad
i love all of winter soldiers reactions to us
agent like he is just not having any of this
you are not captain america just because you have
that shield how dare you stand where he stood
you are not captain america for the most part the
us agent is trying to be the nice guy like he's
trying to work with them i think though like
i said later in the series we're going to see
some cracks start to show like at the end of the
episode where he says stay the hell out of my way
he'll probably turn from really nice guy to
more and more hardcore in his pursuit of the
flag smashers later though the flag smashers
arrive at that safe house seemingly from some
random sympathizer who's just part of the message
boards where everyone talks about their group
and thinks of them as freedom fighters like they
call them robin hood she gets the mystery text
from the power broker saying that he's going to
kill her for stealing all the vaccine stuff that
she's stolen those 18 wheelers there was the big
baron zemo reveal at the end of the series but
i'm not totally ready to say that he's the power
broker it could still be potentially someone else
like thunderbolt ross could be the power broker
it could be another totally different character
if they are following the comics he is going to be
a completely separate person that we haven't met
yet but i'm expecting a couple big twists with his
character like he's just meant to be the shadowy
villain behind the scenes right now like baron's
emo yes he's a villain but i don't think he's
going to wind up being the main villain of the
series and yes the flag smashers seem like the
villain that's the way they're painting them but
they're more like freedom fighters that are slowly
going off the rails so we'll see who winds up
being the worst villains by the end of the series
when they reference the grc caring more about the
blipped people than they do about them the people
who did not get snapped they're referencing the
global repatriation committee and there's a poster
for their organization in the police station when
bucky gets arrested later in the episode i believe
their group is a coalition of world governments
that's sort of responsible for getting all the
blip people and the non-snapped people back
to their original countries and homes that
they came from but for the most part the flag
smashers seem like they're all british there's
still this big question about where they got
their super soldier serum from back on the plane
falcon makes a reference to captain america
civil war when bucky tells him we should just
take the shield from u.s asian falcon tries to
remind him that we were basically all criminals
after civil war you remember what happened he
references sharon carter just because she's going
to show up on the series real soon so they're
kind of reminding you that she exists like hey
remember that character sharon carter she'll be
showing up real soon then when he talks about cap
capping them being on the run for two years doing
their whole secret avengers thing if it wasn't
clear during that time period iron man actually
was helping them duck thunderbolt ross and the
world security council that's why there weren't
any governments that were able to capture them or
throw them in jail during that period they make a
couple funny references to their comic book names
between some of these scenes too like he calls
him white panther because he was in wakanda no
no it's white wolf and falcon gets all upset like
oh wait a minute i wanted a cool wakandan name too
then later in the episode outside of isaiah
bradley's house that little kid calls falcon black
falcon like no no it's just falcon kid but then
bucky's big idea is to take falcon to meet isaiah
bradley the og african-american captain america so
if you never read the comics you're not familiar
with his character after captain america went in
the ice he was the person the government tested
the super soldier serum on when they were trying
to replicate the original serum that they gave to
steve rogers there were 300 people as part of his
test group and isaiah bradley was the only person
who survived it's meant to be a reference to a
real thing that the us military did during world
war ii but during world war ii the us military
tested a bunch of gas masks technology on black
soldiers and wound up poisoning killing hurting a
lot of them later had to make a really big public
apology that's also what they're referencing when
isaiah bradley talks about being quote unquote
thrown in prison and being tested on by the us
military all those years but the whole backstory
behind bucky knowing isaiah bradley is that during
the korean war in the 1950s they had a skirmish
because bucky was hydra he was brainwashed during
this period and he was going up against the u.s
soldiers eventually because he killed all the
people they sent after him the u.s military
sent in isaiah bradley after he survived his super
soldier serum test the way isaiah bradley tells it
too he completely thrashed winter soldier ripped
half of his arm off i just wanted to see if you
got your arm back they also let you know that he's
still every bit as strong as he used to be i mean
obviously he's much much older now but he still
has most of his super strength and when he says he
was in prison for 30 years i think the whole idea
is the military just put him in a private facility
so that they could test him for 30 years so even
though it wasn't formally a prison it was like a
prison for him he also reveals that bucky's people
the hydra people kept sending agents to try and
kill him over all those years too because he was
one of the people that they feared most as bucky
says like captain america also really cool side
note his grandson here who's taking care of him
or helping take care of him is elijah bradley aka
patriot from the marvel young avengers team so we
might see this character come back in a future
young avengers project because we're kind of
seeing those characters pop up like on wandavision
with the twins bucky clarifies the reason why
steve rogers captain america never found out about
isaiah bradley because he probably would have
tried to help him if he did is because bucky never
told him and his existence was so top secret that
cap never found out about it but i think the whole
idea is is that in falcon eventually becoming the
new captain america eventually they'll bring
isaiah bradley back and give him some of the
recognition that he deserves like they're going
to pay that off before the finale at some point
then falcon almost gets arrested by a couple of
really idiot cops who then realize that they're
the avengers but bucky still has to be arrested
because he missed his therapy they have another
funny run-in with u.s agent who they still totally
hate like oh not this guy bailing me out of jail
you even find out the therapist knows him because
they ran missions together back when she was in
the military they do all those funny couples
therapy scenes that they had during the trailer
she even makes a direct reference to couples
therapy like i use this when i'm talking to
couples they're talking about making relationships
with each other they call the staring contest the
soul gazing exercise and eventually they do have
it out over falcon giving up the shield but the
way they leave things just lets you know that it's
going to continue in each of the episodes like
he's going to keep staying on his case to take
the shield back but thanks for making it weird
though doc they have a big standoff with u.s agent
and battle star outside of the station like all
right fine we're not going to work together best
stay out of my way that's obviously going to go
south pretty fast then in slovakia you actually
get a follow-up with the power broker's men at
least they say that's who's coming for them one of
the flag smashers winds up sacrificing himself to
allow the others to get away i don't know who this
lackey's name is or if he's playing a comic book
character but you see him phoning the power broker
to let him know that they got away or whoever the
power broker is going to wind up being then they
follow up with the baron zemo lead in like bucky
says we have to go see my people we have to find
out hydra's secrets and baron zemo knows all of
hydra's secrets so we go back to germany and it's
cell number 2187 which seems like a comic book
reference to the power broker because the power
broker character debuted in the captain america
comics for the first time during 1987. so i don't
know if they're trying to use this easter egg to
say that baron zemo is secretly the power broker
and he's been doing this from inside his cell
or if it'll wind up being somebody different
because baron zemo is not the power broker
in the comics so i don't know if they're changing
things or they're trying to pull a fast one on us
i'm so happy to see daniel bruhl back i did think
that it was a little cliche with some of the other
easter eggs here like they introduced him with
the classical music and the chess set like oh
are we doing a magneto x-men thing like all evil
guys play chess like at the end of the first x-men
movie where professor x shows up inside his cell
and they're playing chess together i think that's
just meant to be a bit of a reference to him being
a mastermind on the series like masters of evil
classic comic book baron zemo because he will be
wearing the classic comic book costume pretty soon
and he'll be pushing around the characters
like falcon and winter soldier like pieces on
a chessboard as for the flag smashers the super
soldier program and the weapons plus program
easter eggs i have a feeling that the power broker
will be connected to the flag smashers in a deeper
way like in the comics because the power broker
tried to replicate the super soldier program and
gave a bunch of characters super powers maybe the
power broker in the mcu is also where all the flag
smashers got their super soldier serum from but
you have to remember that all these other super
soldiers that are running around got diluted
forms of the serum it's not the same thing as
the original formula that steve rogers got so
it's not quite as potent so even though they're
not quite as strong they're still really really
strong compared to normal people the whole idea
with weapons plus on the tv show is that it's
sort of laying the seeds for eventual weapon
x that's really the big payoff down the road with
a new version of wolverine but kevin feike has
already said that they haven't even gotten close
to casting wolverine so i'm not expecting to see
any huge easter eggs for that i think the closest
we'll get to stuff like that is just them trying
to tie all this weapons plus super soldier
stuff to thunderbolt ross in the events of
the incredible hulk film with the abomination and
his weapons plus program but i don't actually know
if thunderbolt ross is supposed to have a cameo
on the series but in the way they're trying to
make everybody feel like they exist in this gray
anti-hero area like there aren't any true villains
there aren't any true heroes or anything like
that everybody's just kind of shades of gray the
government the military people like thunderbolt
ross are going to be doing things on the show that
are just as shady as what's going on with the
villain groups like the flag smashers in baron
zemo all this weapons plus incredible hulk stuff
from thunderbolt ross might also be why u.s agent
directly references the hulk at the beginning of
the episode just to start laying connections back
to the incredible hulk film before they make
any big reveals with the super soldier program
but everyone let me know in the comments who do
you think the power broker is going to wind up
being i've seen some people that want it to be
thunderbolt ross but i'm not expecting it to be
him either if you spotted any other big easter
eggs in the episode that i didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the comments
dc just dropped the brand new suicide squad
trailer so that'll be my next video but i'll do
some more falcon and winter soldier bonus videos
in the next couple of days in my full episode
3 video we'll post next friday just like normal
so i'll update the link here at the end of the
video for the suicide squad trailer when i post
that later today but you can also click here
for my falcon winter soldier episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!